[Music]
let's go to joshua in vancouver hey josh
what's going on man
hey dr john uh can you hear me i can
brother how are
you i'm doing well well can't believe
i'm on the show cool i can't believe i'm
on
the phone with you
thanks for your time no thank you man so
what's up how can i help
okay so
uh my question is um as a solo parent
how can i best raise two young daughters
to be healthy and confident especially
kind of a
part of the question my next part of the
question is
would it be better for them
that i wait until they're adults for me
to look for a partner
um yeah
wait for them to be adults so
where is mom
mom moved out
about two years ago
she left the country and she's living
with someone else
okay hmm yeah
how's the last couple of years been
up and down hmm
yikes man
walk me through how that how that
initial transition happened did she just
drop a bomb on you one day did your
relationship slowly lose steam what
happened
um what happened was
well i had a i had an inkling you know
something was up she was spending a lot
more time on a certain
phone game and then
found out that way that she had been uh
well actually she went on a trip
and then um when she got back that's
when i found out okay yeah the the trip
was not for what she was intended to go
it was to meet someone else gotcha
yeah
and how old are your girls
uh they're eight and my youngest is
turning uh
seven in october oh man so they were six
and
five when this happened yeah yeah and um
well unfortunately this hasn't been like
the first time that i've been left on my
own with the girls
so well don't just don't just stop there
i mean what happened
um
well the first time i guess uh
she wasn't
feeling as if though
i'm trying to remember here from the top
of my head now
um she had moved out to go live with a
relative
i
to remember why it was something
something that she just couldn't she
didn't want to i don't know she couldn't
live with me or something okay
well or her baby girls right
yeah so tell me about these two
wonderful young daughters tell me about
them
well they they really are wonderful they
have uh kept me
going cause my face is strong uh
they're
they're they're opposite in nature and
one of them is uh really social the
other one's really quiet more like me
and um
they have been uh
they have been my everything they've
they've been able to help me keep going
that's awesome
and vice versa right you've kept them
plugged into oh yeah for sure oh and by
the way you had to do this during covid
so that's fun right
yeah that was interesting navigating
single parenting in vancouver
in a pandemic good grief man
so to answer your first question
how do you raise
two daughters tell me tell me that first
question again
i'm just trying to give them the best
chance so i guess the the way
i phrased the question was how can i how
can i raise them to be healthy and
confident okay
so
there's a couple of things here number
one
their mom abandoned them
mom said i would rather a life that does
not include you in it
than one that does
and so
strength and confidence
is anchored to
our core narrative our core parent and
when our parent abandons us
leaves us
that leaves us untethered completely
right
and so you
are going to have to be that connection
that tethering that grounding for them
in a way that will feel
more than you can
bear it
sometimes right
yeah what does that look like every day
that means every day you gotta set up
breakfast with them
if you if you can like and i know single
parents are working 45 jobs to make
stuff work right
um that looks like your social life's
gonna be greatly altered because you're
gonna be spending time with them right
and
you're gonna be setting up situations
where they can go play and have
relationships and be successful as well
right so it's going to be just this mix
mismatch
mix smash whatever the words are it's
going to be a hodgepodge how about that
i like hodgepodge yeah um
it's going to be tough is what i'm
telling you oh yeah
do they know mom do they talk to mom do
they have any interaction with her
well um
are you legally married are you divorced
where where's the status here
yeah let me uh fill you in here so
uh with the court we got um obviously i
have the primary what's called here
primary
parenting
um basically the almost like full
custody kind of thing and she has um
what's it called
she can
contact contact with the kids so we set
up at least one day
every week where she could uh video
message them or talk to them through um
the messenger
so yeah and uh
it's it's kind of uh it's not going to
be
ongoing i don't i don't know how it's
going to be because she just
to throw another bomb on top she just
had another kid i i believe
in this month
yeah yeah at some point um
man i'm
i'm going to say something that i
usually don't say on this show
i'm usually about
reconciliation and i'm usually about get
have a parent stay as connected as
possible to their kids as much as
possible
um
i'm also it's important that you never
run down the other parent right even in
these messy co-printing situations
i want you to meet with a child
psychologist asap have you done that
already
no
so that's a must because i want you to
get some very clear guidance from
somebody in your area who knows they've
got more than 10 minutes with you on the
phone um
it i do not like this
electronic
mother
connectivity
right that makes sense that feels like
it's gonna be more damaging in the long
term than just cutting off all
communication
that's what i was uh thinking in my
heart too i i hate that that that's
there
and i i know that in the back of my my
head
but you will also have to deal with and
this is a very real thing
your wife or your ex-wife at some point
will say
daddy's the one that wouldn't let me
talk to you i tried
does that make sense
and your daughters will look at you and
say dad why'd you take our mom from us
and that yeah there's gonna have to be
some really clear guidance there in that
relationship and so i want you to
meet with a child psychologist asap if
your daughters aren't in counseling they
need to be
okay
yeah um
their anchor to the world has left them
and they are
all yeah they are just hanging in the
wind and
i want to push on something you said a
little bit okay you said that they are
the ones keeping you tied to reality it
cannot be that way it has to be the
other way around
those girls will feel that weight that
it's our job to keep dad stable and to
make sure dad's okay because mom left
him and that's a burden that an
eight-year-old or a six-year-old is not
strong enough or designed to carry
oh for sure let me let me quickly
reiterate that uh i i thought i was more
answering like um
what they were like like these um
these two
individuals i was trying to explain what
they were like but for me what uh what
keeps me going
is my faith in god for sure okay
well i i never want them to feel like
now that mom left it's their job to make
sure dad doesn't go crazy
exactly you know i understand that okay
so
if you haven't already um do you have a
group that you meet with
uh i just started to
the churches that i'm attending just
started opening up more of the
the group so i signed up for one
hopefully like go back to me soon good
sign up for a group there if you haven't
gone to meet with a counselor i would
recommend it even if it's an online
counselor you can go to
betterhelp.com deloney i got to deal
with them you can take that man but get
it yeah i did i did it actually
excellent good for you good for you so
getting connected with somebody that can
help you begin to parse this apart
because that leads me to the second part
of this question which is
should you just not date until they're
should you not find another partner
until they are
out of the house the answer to that is
no man don't do that to yourself right
um
the recommendation here is often around
it's out of the 12-step language but
about a year after somebody passes away
about a year after somebody just up and
abandons everybody
um especially if it's just one of those
snap your fingers i'm on a trip i'm out
taking a year to learn who you are
getting your feet on the ground right
what kind of parent are you going to be
what kind of home are you trying to try
to create here before you start dating
again
two years out man
man i highly recommend leaning into
social situations going to grab coffee
with somebody right and if have you done
that yet
no no i'm still trying to
i think it's going to take me longer
than three years to figure out who i am
sure well you want hey listen you won't
have yourself totally figured out
brother and the moment you think you do
you're going to meet somebody they're
going to knock your socks off and all
that's going to change right it's more
about making sure the blood stopped
right okay it's making sure that that
wound is healing
and so what you don't want to do is go
create a codependent relationship here
where
some you're going to be so exhausted
after a few years it's going to be
tempting to get somebody else to help
babysit your kids with you right and
that's what you don't want
um
and then obviously be careful and smart
about who you bring home and make sure
that you're not just having a rotating
cadre of potential girlfriends coming
through the house because that's a lot
for your kids right
of course if you do decide hey i'm
serious with somebody
then man y'all go straight to a
premarital counselor where they can walk
you through what joining homes is going
to look like what co-parenting's gonna
look like what
how are you gonna involve mom at one
point when she decides she's just gonna
swing back into the girl's life and all
that's gonna help you just pull each one
of those things apart and create some
sort of
context some sort of
forum for how you are going to handle
questions as they arise which they will
right but no man just staying
don't feel like you have to do that for
them for you
they can still grow up to be wonderful
well-adjusted young women so i didn't
answer your original question here's
your original question
you let those girls know that they are
brilliant
that they can do hard things and not
just with words only give them tasks let
them be a part of the household the
operation of the household right so the
temptation is going to be to take all
their chores away because you know
they're sad no they're going to be
they're going to function in the house
they're going to help with dinner
they're going to help you when y'all go
grocery shopping they're gonna help when
you are cleaning the house they're gonna
know they have a role in that home
and you're gonna honor that role by
having high standards by loving them by
teaching not losing your mind on them
right
their their esteem who they are is going
to come through participation in that
relationship in that family unit does
that make sense
yeah that makes good sense that actually
helped answer my question um i'm doing
an okay job then well yeah and
the tendency is to either put your foot
way on the gas and try to control
everything so this never happens again
and you can't do that because you'll
suffocate somebody or it's just to i
don't want to push them because i know
they're hurting
and then the kids end up with no
boundaries man and a kids crave
boundaries right
and then making sure you take each one
of them out on a date so that they know
individually they are special and loved
and making sure that you go take care of
you that you're exercising you're eating
right you're going out with friends
you're going on dates too
and so here's here's what i'm getting at
when you're at home you are fully at
home
you are the the the electronics are off
you are in their world you are asking
about their weird dolls or dragons or
whatever things they're into and you're
learning it and you're on all fours
playing with them
and then when you're at work you are
fully in work
because being guilty while you're at
work doesn't do anything except make you
less
less of a good employee and when you are
out on a date you are fully invested in
that date
right
and those little girls are with a
babysitter that you trust or with a
parent that you trust and they are um
safe and secure there you
have going halfway in on your date isn't
gonna help them either does that make
sense be where you are fully and when
you're with them be all in on them right
yeah so be just uh learn to be in the
moment kind of thing absolutely and
again i'm going to stick by
the
the always advice don't talk bad about
mom
um they will ask why did mom leave us
mommy's not doing well right now or
mommy chose to go live in another house
that's a choice she made
um
i know we miss her don't we
and
you've had those nights where your kids
are bawling just saying i miss mommy
have you had those
no but they my oldest has asked about uh
her whereabouts and why yeah
and say mommy chose to go live somewhere
else and i miss her and i know you miss
her too
yeah no yeah we have had uh those
conversations yeah
if they haven't had the balling fits the
why not i want my mom
um
they're coming okay
they're coming
and on those nights when
your daughter says i just want my mom
dad i don't want to talk to you about
this i just want to talk to my mom
don't get your feelings hurt because
they're kids right yeah they're just
young children and they're going to miss
their mom it's right for them to miss
their mom it's right for daughters to
want to be around their moms
um
i mean that's a special special
relationship that your ex-wife just
stepped out on
ah it breaks my heart man so here's the
thing my answer was all over the place
and i apologize for being kind of rambly
um
how do you know your doc
your daughters are gonna grow up to be
strong
loved
young women because their dad loved them
dad told him the truth when dad was with
them he was fully with them
dad made sure there was time for each
one of them to be known dad got them the
mental health trauma help that they need
and this is trauma because mom abandoned
them
mom moved out on them
and you can use any word you want this
is trauma this is abandonment
and they need to get professional help
for this especially at this young age
with play therapy there can be some
magical things that play therapists can
do with young kids in this situation
and you got to trust them and you got to
lean into them and when they lash out at
you you can't take it personally even
though it's going to hurt which means
you're going to have to have your own
network of people that love and support
you
and when they
start pushing your boundaries as they
get older
expect it
love them for having autonomy and
strength and wanting to know how far the
limits of your love
they can push because they see how far
mom's limits they see how far mom's
tether went it was really short
and then mom cut it
and so they're going to want to find out
how far they can push dad before he'll
cut him loose too and you're never going
to cut him loose
because you love those baby girls
i'm so sorry you're living in this man
make sure you got people make sure
you're honoring yourself your body your
mind
and let those girls know they are
brilliant they are strong they are
beautiful
and i say this almost every show make
sure you are getting in your 30 second
hugs a day with them if they're cool
with that
make sure you're touching their face
you're looking them in the eye
and that they can feel it that they
matter to you
sorry you're going through this brother
whoo joshua sorry sorry man
but hey you know what i'm glad you're
the dad i'm glad you're the dad it's got
to deal with this and sit in that gap
for those girls they're lucky to have
you brother